no hay tintes de nosotros iguales
la educación para los más jóvenes ha
estado cerrados durante meses ya era
difícil antes de la pandemia encontrar
cuidado para los niños y ahora los
padres están atrapados sin saber cuándo
y qué opciones tienen para la educación
de sus hijos y la forma en la que lo veo
es que los problemas grandes demandan
soluciones grandes
[Música]
y yo vaya tiene grandes planes planes
para volver a traer los trabajos y la
manufactura y crear los empleos con
energía limpia con más beneficios para
los trabajadores trabajar para las
familias en vez de las instituciones
crediticias con nuestro sistema
económico
le ha dado beneficios a los millonarios
y problemas a los demás pero podemos
construir una mejor economía e invertir
en las familias y arreglar lo que está
roto
whitney que nuestros planes de yo para
hacer la economía mejor
hace que las empresas sean responsables
y repara la inequidad racial y además
lucha contra la corrupción en washington
déjenme decirles un plan de joe biden
que es muy esencial para mi corazón el
cuidado para los niños lo que más quería
yo cuando era niña era ser una maestra
me encanta enseñar en texas a los niños
fue mi primer trabajo
lo que casi me ha salvado ha sido el
cuidado de los niños un día mi tía ya no
solamente para ver cómo yo estaba y
pensó que estaba bien pero yo me rompí y
empecé a llorar
estaba tratando de mantenerlo dentro de
mí pero si no es mío y dado como para
los niños era imposible trabajar le dije
que iba a renunciar a mi trabajo
mientras mi corazón se rompiese
y luego me dijo las palabras que
cambiaron mi vida no puedo llegar mañana
pero llegaré
conscientes maletas y se quedó durante
yo estoy aquí esta noche gracias a macul
ya fondo me but for it y aprendí una
verdad fundamental nadie lo hace solo y
aquí estamos dos generaciones de padres
que trabajan y si usted tiene un hijo y
no tiene una tía está solo y esto está
mal hemos construido una infraestructura
y sistemas de comunicaciones para que
las personas puedan trabajar y eso nos
ayuda a todos porque hace que la
economía funcione pero es momento de
reconocer que el cuidado de esos niños
es parte
esta infraestructura básica de nuestra
relación es para las familias
y cama la van a hacer que el cuidado
para los niños sea accesible a todas las
familias porque sea
la escuela primaria y el preescolar sea
universal esto es solo un plan pero les
da la idea de cómo haremos que este país
funcione para todos somos la ignorancia
y la incompetencia de donald trump han
sido siempre un peligro para nuestro
país el commit 19
fue la prueba más grande para trump
vigila perdió miserablemente hoy eeuu
que la mayor parte de las muertes del
cómic 19 en el mundo y un colapso
económico que están pasando además una
factura mayor para las familias negras y
latinas hay muchas personas en riesgo de
perder sus hogares sus tiendas están
frente a una amenaza y esta crisis es
muy deseable y no tenía que ser así esta
crisis
de los republicanos y de donald trump el
3 de noviembre vamos a hacer que todos
ellos paguen por su responsabilidad así
que me van a votar con una mascarilla o
por correo tómense sus teléfono ahora y
manda en un mensaje real con la palabra
voto al 30 3 30 y pidiendo fáctica
debemos hacer que yo y camela sean
elegidos y después de noviembre
necesitamos seguir luchando para que las
cosas grandes se hagan y seguimos en
esta pelea para que cuando nuestros
hijos y nuestros nietos nos pregunten
que hicimos durante este capítulo
sombrío de nuestra historia los podamos
mirar directamente a los ojos y decirles
nos organizamos persistimos y cambiamos
a eeuu